thank you
so you live half the time right here in
Israel and half the time in Florida so I
don't know that there's ever been a
guest that I'm supposed to sit down with
in Jerusalem in this exact spot more
more than you but I want to actually
start somewhere else for just a minute
or so because you also grew up in Long
Island like basically 10 minutes from
where I grew up from right and I thought
for for people that don't know your bio
could you give just sort of a one minute
bio that'll then get us to everything
else that you've done sure son for rabbi
um thought about becoming a rabbi my
father had a thousand member
congregation he was a great Rabbi uh
when I told them I was thinking of
becoming a rabbi he cried uh he begged
me not to do it I was gonna say Tears of
Joy or yeah
it's a tough gig be a doctor or a lawyer
to make some money and don't have a
thousand uh bosses telling you what to
do even though he loved his job uh sent
me off to Columbia University became a
lawyer lived basically uh in the area
where I grew up for most of my life
until I became the US ambassador to
Israel and moved here in in 2017. okay
so you probably are the most influential
U.S ambassador to Israel probably in its
existence I mean I know do you want to
Pat yourself on the back is that fair I
mean the New York Times said that and
there are no fans so uh oh so they might
have been sticking you and when they
said that they said that so we'll we'll
refer to them for that so so let's start
just with exactly where we are at the
moment and and the incredible history
and geography of of where we're at
before we get into some of the politics
of the region that you've really helped
shape which has clearly led to an
incredibly flourishing Israel in my five
days here I can't I can't believe what's
going on here yeah well we're we're
about
a 10 minute walk from my home and we are
right here where that gold Dome is is
the um is the holiest place for the
Jewish people it's it's now called The
Dome of the Rock uh it was built uh
maybe 1500 years ago but three thousand
years ago is where the Jewish temple
stood uh and that Temple stood in two
different forms but it stood for a
thousand years and it was destroyed the
second time in the year 70 and ever
since then until 1967 the Jewish people
have been praying in in every country
whether it's uh you know North Africa
Eastern Europe the United States for 2
000 years Jews have prayed to return to
this land to return exactly to that spot
uh and in 1967 right after the Six Day
War where Jerusalem was reunified it
came to be so you know even though this
this Dome and this mosque looked very
old and they are relatively speaking
they're pretty recent when you think of
of Jewish history that goes back 3 500
years right so it's hard for people to
imagine but because everyone thinks that
the Western Wall is actually the holy
site in Judaism but it's the Temple
mount that the mosque which is right
there and then the Dome of the Rock are
built on here and the and the Western
Wall is actually just a retaining wall
it's a retaining wall it's a lot bigger
than that it goes much further if you go
under underground you can see it goes
further but it's a retaining world the
holiest sign Judaism is the Temple mount
it is under that it's called the dumb of
the rock because The Rock The Rock The
Rock is the rock on which Abraham was
called to sacrifice his son Isaac and he
passed the test that was given to him by
God and God promised he'd become the
father of many nations it All Began
there under that rock and then of course
that's where Solomon built the first
temple it's enormously important to
choose and and the proof of it is that
uh you know for for thousands of years
when we didn't have it we prayed for it
uh look the other things if you you know
you see the mosque uh to the to the
right the the oxa mosque is the is the
silver monster right
so if you go into Damascus train you I
couldn't do that but if you went into
the masking parade you would you would
bow down and you would face South you
would face Mecca your back would be to
the temple okay so the the temple uh is
not of even the Holiness of Jerusalem is
very secondary to the Muslim World
relative to the Holiness of Mecca you
know uh uh but Jerusalem was not
mentioned in the Quran it's mentioned
699 times in the Old Testament and all
that being said all the religions are
being respected you can see Muslim
worshipers right literally right there I
don't know if they can quite be seen by
our camera and then plenty of obviously
of Jewish words
essentially more than them being
respected because you know you see here
straight ahead is the Western Wall up on
top is the mosque and to the left is the
Church of the Holy Sepulcher which is
one of the holy sites in Christianity
now if you're a Jew if you're a Muslim
if you're a Christian if you're an
atheist you can go to the Church of the
Holy Sepulcher and go to the Western
Wall if you want to go up on the Temple
Mount all right and you're not a Muslim
you have one access point which is this
rickety
gate where you go through security
there's 10 other access for believers
you know with labor fruit as Believers
here but you're just Muslims and uh and
if you happen to be a jeweler Christian
and you go up through this gate onto the
Temple Mount and you begin to pray
you're escorted off the Moscow the U.N
will uh write up a couple uh
recommendations so it's not equal access
it's actually better access the the is
the state of Israel affords better
access to Muslims a far better access to
Muslims than it does to Christians and
Jews and it's and it's odd because you
know it's referred to generally as the
status quo but if you look at the treaty
between Jordan and Israel the treaty
says that both Nations regardless of
sovereignty will afford complete and
equal and unfettered access to every
abrahamic Faith as to every holy site
uh and that's not done here it's not
observed right so it's sort of ironic
and then we'll move on to some other
stuff that that Israel is actually
affording more courtesies than than was
happening before you know yeah Israeli
control but and oxa has been the theme
since since 1929 when there was a
massacre in Hebron where hundreds of
Jews were killed the the false claim
that the Jews are storming the mouse
taking over the mosque it's always been
kind of the rallying point whenever uh
Arab terrorists have sought to uh to to
create violence against the Jewish
people all right so let's uh we I know
we could do the history uh clearly all
day long for many days so let's let's
get to the broader Middle East though
because you were integral in what has
happened here over these last now you
know seven years or so so talk to me
about when when you became Ambassador I
mean were you was that the immediate
plan like we're gonna do this stuff did
it sort of fall in your lap and did you
ever think it was even possible
so I was I was the first Ambassador
appointed in the Trump Administration
even before he took office and we put
out a press release and I was quoted
with the permission of the president was
saying that I look forward to serving my
country from an embassy in its Eternal
undivided Capital Jerusalem Israel's
undivided Capital so this was number one
on my agenda right so that was before
the deals even fast before we even took
office yeah uh we worked on it uh really
hard
um we uh in in less than a year the
president recognized Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel and then May 14th uh
of uh 2018 exactly five years ago this
coming May 14th which is also Israel's
day of independence we opened up our
Embassy and you know the entire world
predicted that this would create endless
Wars and Untold violence and and it
really didn't not at all there was
basically nothing basically nothing and
you know why because everybody who's
looked at this knows that Jerusalem is
the internal undivided capital of the
Jewish people I mean you have to know it
if you read the Bible right Bible sells
more books on Amazon than any other book
anybody reads the Bible knows that
Jerusalem belongs to the Jewish people
including most of the Christian world so
in most of the Muslim world and most of
the Muslims actually consider you know
Mecca to be holy far less Jerusalem so
uh not surprisingly that's the least so
did that embolden you guys once once
that was done and settled and it didn't
inflame the world then you go okay now
we can really do so it gave us a real
Tailwind uh in in two respects number
one uh gave us the ability to make more
positive moves that have been neglected
for years with regard to Israel so
recognize the Israel's sovereignty over
the Golan Heights which was never going
to leave Israel was never going to be
given back to a butcher like Bashar
Assad and then we started focusing more
on the Palestinians and how to you know
maybe choreograph some sort of a peace
plan but what we found was and I think
this is the key Point people said you're
going to make you're going to create
violence
by supporting Israel and supporting
Jerusalem just to the contrary I mean we
actually created an environment of that
was conducive to peace why because the
Arab Nations that we made peace with
right they looked at our relationship
with Israel and said you know we want to
get in on that you know we want to be an
ally of the United States the same way
that Israel is an ally how do we get
there how do we get closer to each other
and you know in many cases we said well
the road to that kind of relationship
has to run through Israel you have to
normalize with issue you can't you know
be closer to America when you're you
know shouting death to Israel you're
fighting our most important Ally maybe
in the world but certainly in the Middle
East
and so our our closest to Israel was
actually an asset in our relationship
with the Arab world and and it drew us
closer to them and ultimately
um uh you know we we would we would sit
with these with these countries started
off with the UAE and um and and we said
look you know and by the way uh you know
Trump said this on his very first trip
he went to Saudi Arabia he started with
52 Muslim nations and he said something
he doesn't get credit for he said look
this idea that Israel is going to be
destroyed put it out of your mind just
forget about it it's a pipe dream it's
never going to happen and it's going to
keep you at at this dead arms length
with us that's number one number two in
a radical Islamic terrorism okay it's
your problem first not ours okay you
know you stop it before it crosses the
Atlantic Ocean and if you do that you
will find that America a level of
friendship you've not experienced before
so you actually set the tone you know
very early in the term but but we we
worked on that theme throughout and and
as we uh as we got closer to the end of
the term we found these countries they
they saw a window closing how can we you
know align ourselves with America you
know in a way that starts to resemble
yeah this alliance with Israel how can
we build this you know this uh this kind
of Circle of trust you know around a
common threat of Iran and and you know
it it involved you know some you know
fabulous discussions negotiations and
ultimately results I don't know how much
you can say on this but how close were
you I mean there were all the rumors
that there were going to be all these
other reproachments and obviously you
guys literally just ran out of time and
now unfortunately our Administration is
looking at the Middle East very
differently yeah we would have uh
normalized with uh Saudi Arabia would
have normalized with Israel by now if we
were still in
um it's it's a massive Game Changer I
mean you're talking about now the the
leader of the Muslim World normal guys
this really just changes it really ends
you know ends just puts a period on the
arab-israeli conflict uh and it unites
everyone against radicalism you know
when I met with uh the foreign minister
of uh of the UAE
um about six months after the Abraham
Accords there had been a war uh in Gaza
uh they're getting all their news from
Al Jazeera which is very unfavorable to
Israel I sat and I met with him and I
said to him and how are we doing he said
no we're passing with flying colors and
he said to you know why and and what he
said to me was the wars of the um of the
21st century this was before Russia and
Ukraine which may be the exception that
proves the rule but he says the worst of
the 21st century are Wars of ideology
they're not Wars between nations anymore
and the main ideological war is
extremism versus the moderates and the
moderates have to win and to us the
Abraham Accords is all about the
moderates winning the war when you uh
when you were when the whole
Administration was you know packing
their bags and then there's incoming
people did you have any communication
with the incoming people saying hey guys
and I asked Jared Kushner here this as
well hey we're on the path here was
there anything that you could have done
that would have continued everything and
look hopefully it'll continue maybe in
two years yeah well look for for the
first six months it was uh anything
Trump was uh was you know verboten you
know no we're not gonna and then they
realize you know the Abraham courts are
so popular among so many different
people Democrats as well they began to
embrace them but it's not about
embracing in my paying lip service to it
it's about being a friend uh to to Saudi
Arabia now look Saudi Arabia is an
imperfect country
um there's no question about it and they
have that one incident which is horrific
but you know what you know uh uh you
know I'm I'm not going to quote Jesus
because I'm uh I'm a Jewish but you know
you know whoever's without sin you know
you know come forward you know and no
one's coming forward
Saudi Arabia could be a very good friend
of the United States they have been in
the past we can advance that
relationship and what Weinstein really
has been to
really push them away and they're
furious with America right now as are
some of the other Gulf Nations they
don't see America standing for um for
moderate Sunni Islam the way we promised
we would and the way we should and so uh
you know what do you think about the
Abraham Accords tend to think of it as
you know bilateral relations between
Israel and UAE or Bahrain or Morocco
they're not it's a triangle right Israel
and then Arab country at the Basin the
US is at the Apex and U.S plays the most
important role everybody's looking
through the U.S for what they can what
they can achieve in that relationship
we're the strongest country in the world
we're the most important country in the
world and everybody wants to be close
with us and as we push countries away we
dilute the abrahamic courts right and if
it ain't us it's it's most likely China
that's a very different world to be
right I mean look somebody's moving
closer to China Russia and Iran and
that's not a shot against Israel it's a
shot against America that's a signal to
America guys you know this works both
ways you want to push us away
and I will push you away as well I want
to ask you one other thing because when
we got here I really didn't know what to
expect I was bringing my team we were
going to tour historical sites we were
going to talk to people like you but
what I'm realizing now just in five days
in Jerusalem is that there is an
incredible uh strength here despite the
divisions despite the security stuff and
you know you live you live in the
promised land and what I would say is
the other promised land of Florida so
what is what is that connection the
freedom that's happening in Florida the
freedom and strength that's happening
here to me that's what has to be
exported to save America which you know
here in Jerusalem it this is what every
one of our major cities and they're not
going to look like geographically but
the spirit of this place is incredible
and it's so different than what I'm
seeing in New York in San Francisco and
all of those places what what can Israel
export to the United States that might
help in our current crisis you know what
I think I think the most important thing
is uh is meaning a sense of purpose in
life that there's a reason to be on this
Earth and we only get you know 70 80 90
years of on this Earth You Want To Make
It Count
there's a real sense of purpose here
that that people are here for a reason
they're building something they're
building something that matters that
counts they're bringing back to life
biblical prophecies they're they're
fulfilling you know judeo-christian
values
um we've grown untethered from that in
the United States you know we don't have
relationships interpersonal
relationships like like we used to
people go on dates you know by texting
by what's happening I mean everybody's
looking at their phone all day long I
mean there's about you know they
invented the iPhone here so it's not
like they don't do it here too but it's
there is a sense that there's something
bigger than ourselves that we are that's
driving us forward and I gotta tell you
when you lose that uh it's a quick trip
to the bottom it really is I mean you
need to have that sense of meaning and
purpose and and America had that America
was you know it was the for many people
it was the New Jerusalem that that's
that's what our Founders thought about
it they they they were Christians who
you this is the you know as the new
jerusalemist the new you know it's a
shining City on a Hill is a place of
purpose that would be a light to the
Nations and uh we don't teach that
anymore we don't uh people don't really
understand what why America was was
created uh why it's great
um and um that that is a I think a very
valuable message that could come out of
Jerusalem and the whole state of Israel
now I have a request for you that just
popped into my head sure what do you say
we do this twice a year we do it once in
Florida and once in Israel and we keep
working this thing out what do you think
it would be my pleasure thank you
Ambassador thanks Dave if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about international issues
check out our International playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell